[Music]
so
[Applause]
[Music]
so
baby
[Music]
[Applause]
so
[Music]
you
[Applause]
so
[Music]
hi everybody family i just want to thank
you so much for joining us tonight
uh my name is dawn jacobs and i'm a
member here at the table
and i just want to welcome you again to
just joining us tonight and
i'm just getting settled in for this
particular service
um this is an interest interesting
sunday because today specifically
is national coming out day for those of
you who don't know
what that is this is a day that happens
every single year
uh is october the 11th specifically
today
that is reserved for sharing stories
specifically in the lgbt community for
folks who
are just wanting to share where they
where they've been coming from
um and i posted something about my
personal story on my social media today
and as right right as i'm writing this
i'm talking about
really the shame that i've been kind of
carrying that goes along with
this um for the last several years
and i started thinking about um tonight
for you know the table and i started
thinking that you know shame is
something that we kind of
all deal with um we're it's not just
specifically
uh with you know the queer community
shame is something that comes in all
shapes and sizes
with all kinds of different things that
we have in life whether that's something
you
have maybe gone through maybe a divorce
maybe
there's been some like shame with mental
health such as like a depression or
something to that effect
um could be through you know history of
drug abuse or an abortion these can
bring on
shame um but shame can also come in
you know seemingly s you know different
packages they could come
from you know just your relationship
with your spouse
um shame with trying to be a good parent
shame with maybe our personal finances
again shame just is something that we
carry
all the time with us um and what i
love about our community and i love
about being here at the table is that we
can come
here and find a sense of community
of people who have also deal with their
sets of shame
and we let we have the ability to let it
go
we have the opportunity to lay it down
at the cross
to lay it down at jesus feet and to find
people
that will help carry walk with us
and possibly even lighten the load to
maybe the shame doesn't affect us as
much as we as it does on a regular basis
um for me coming out um as a gay person
it was important for me to have a sense
of community and i have found that and
i've been so thankful and grateful for
that
um the table is a different type of
community
that is also still helpful so i hope and
i pray that you guys
will will find that sense of community
here
so um again welcome we we are so
thankful that you are here
uh just a couple announcements um to
just i want
you to save the date for november the
first
we are going to be having our one year
anniversary
for the table uh that's going to be
coming up here pretty soon
some details are forthcoming so all i'm
going to say is to mark that in your
calendar
circle it put it in your phone um it's
going to be coming
out very soon the second thing i want to
mention to you tonight
is that we are having our welcome to the
table class that is going to be
right after the service so if you would
make sure make a point to
join us there's going to be details
about that coming
up at the end of the service tonight so
stick around
for all of that so if you wouldn't mind
we're just going to start off the
evening with a prayer
lord just thank you so very much for all
the folks that are uh tuning in that are
listening that they are wherever they
are if they're listening live at this
moment or they're catching up some other
time
i pray that you will just open up their
hearts
be with them open up their minds i pray
that this
will be as blessing into their lives
i pray that this will also connect them
back to you and back to who your son is
in christ center praying
amen
thanks don um thanks for sharing that
with us too
uh i love what he was saying um just
about
the freedom of being who you are and
getting rid of shame
um there's a verse that was standing out
to me this week while i was getting
ready for worship it's in galatians five
um and it's talking about freedom and it
says it's for
freedom that christ has set us free
so stand firm then and don't let
yourselves be burdened by a yoke of
slavery
and uh brett's gonna be speaking about
women
um tonight and i was just thinking about
how it's so easy for us
i feel like sometimes in our culture to
take on things that we weren't meant to
carry
um and sometimes that's a cultural thing
sometimes it's just our own
maybe something in our family that we
were brought up to believe or something
um you know what i mean that we put on
ourselves
but i hope that as you enter into a
place of worship tonight with us
um i hope that you feel the sense of
freedom
that jesus came to offer us the sense
that um
we aren't bound um to anyone else's
um idea of who we were meant to be but
that we are free in christ to be the
people that he created us as
um yeah so we're gonna go in
and share a worship video with you guys
that we did with a few of the other
women um that are on our team
and i hope that's a blessing to you guys
as you guys um
yeah join us in just a moment to reflect
on jesus and who he is and who he
created us to be
[Music]
you unravel me
with a melody
you surround me with
a song
of deliverance
from my enemies
till all my fears
are gone
i am a child
of god
[Music]
you have chosen me
i've been born again
to your family
[Music]
i am the child
of god
[Music]
i am a child of god
is
[Music]
you rescue me
i am the child
of god
[Music]
i am a child
of god
[Music]
i is
um
[Music]
is
break
[Music]
[Applause]
break every day
break every chain break every day
[Music]
oh
is
[Music]
there is power in the name of jesus
to break everything break every chain
break every shift
break every chain bring every drink
to break every shape break every day
break every
[Music]
so i could
asleep
[Music]
i am
yes i am
[Music]
death could not hold you
the praise of the
[Music]
you have no equal
[Applause]
[Music]
is
christ my king
what a beautiful name it is
nothing can stand against what a
beautiful name it is
what a beautiful day
[Music]
[Applause]
yours is the glory
yours is the name
[Music]
what a beautiful name it is the name of
jesus what a beautiful name it is
the name of jesus
[Music]
ah that was lovely lovely lovely thank
you ladies
um for leading us and i know it's
different you know interacting online
but
i love um just those moments to kind of
close our eyes and
be able to sit with jesus and adore who
he is
and yeah it's really really it's just a
beautiful thing so
um thank you all for joining us tonight
um
grace and peace to everyone it's great
to be with you all
and as don mentioned happy national
coming out day
uh to all of our lgbtq folks um who call
the table home
um i know that is i mean i can't even
imagine that
just the battle that is to um take that
step
and um to come out just take so much
courage and
um just that acknowledgement especially
in you know religious
circles often it's it's just that much
harder as we talked about last week and
so
um just i just want you to know we love
you so much and
we are enriched by your presence we're
better for it so
thank you for um being among us it's
wonderful
so we are in um part three of our series
titled scripture uh dealing with
difficult texts
and two weeks ago we discussed really
how to kind of um
think about and approach scripture kind
of as a whole and in that message
i contended that the primary point of
scripture
is to point us to jesus right it does
not point to itself
it the scripture doesn't say look at me
look at me everyone i'm i'm
i'm the best i'm i'm ultimate i am god
believe on me and you shall be saved
i know the bible points away from itself
towards christ
and and kind of what we named was that
at the very least that's that's really
how the early church
fathers and mothers read the bible and
interacted with it um which meant you
know sometimes when they came across
something that did not seem uh
in line with the nature and character of
christ then they often read that passage
metaphorically
um or they would even just reinterpret
it until it lined up with the love of
christ
and um and sometimes they were quite
creative about this we i mentioned one
example
um that i'll just touch on again for
those who missed it um so saint
augustine was a
or just an amazing theologian and
a great mind in the faith and this is
how he engaged with scripture and so
um you know when he came across the
passage about jesus
clearing out the temple um with whips
uh augustine said like oh come on jesus
would never do
that what what this passage is is
teaching us that okay this is about the
way
that christ drives the evil from our
hearts so he gave it a metaphorical or
figurative reading
of that story um now as i mentioned a
few weeks ago i don't think that's
actually a text we need to read in that
way um
but no matter the point is um that
you know the purpose of the bible is to
lead us to christ
and then to really to fashion us to mold
us to shape us into his character image
and love so
that was week one and then last week
we took this approach to the bible and
basically applied it to texts
that are commonly known as um the
clobber passages
if i'd had more foresight i would have
swapped messages
and done that last week's message this
week but anyway
uh so last week we looked at the clobber
they're known as the clobber passages
um and they're they're normally the
passages in the bible read as applying
to people in the lgbtq community
uh and so if you're interested in that
topic kind of how i approached it um you
can go back
to um last week on the podcast and and
listen to
to that message uh but tonight we're
going to shift our focus
to text speaking about women
so with that in mind the title of my
message is the puzzling history
of the bible and women
so um let me kind of frame things up
like this for the last uh probably
17 years 16 17 years um i have been what
is called a
christian um egalitarian uh so let me
give you i'm gonna give you a few
definitions on this so this is um
christian egalitarianism
it it holds to the equality of men and
women
and places no gender-based restrictions
on what roles they can hold in the
family or
the church now this is in contrast
to what's known as christian
complementarianism
i know these are some big words uh and
complementarianism holds to the equality
of men and women in their
personhood while believing they have
separate but equal roles in the family
society and the church
so for example a complementarian church
would
would would have some restrictions on
women right they would say okay
um you could if you're a woman like you
could teach
you know um children about the bible but
as far as you know a woman
preaching a sermon um you know kind of
like i'm doing now
or you know going on staff as like a
pastor
that'd be a no go um and now to
to be fair they wouldn't say that's
because they believe you know women are
lesser than
um but the argument would go they it's
it's simply that men and women have
different
roles you know god-given roles there are
different parts to play
um and of course this becomes kind of
contested because
leadership and authority is is at least
um partly how we honor and kind of
communicate trust to people
so you know if you say these two groups
are equal but only one group can lead
then you know it kind of begs the
question
like is it really that equal but all
right no matter so
um so as i mentioned for the last 17
years or so i've been
an egalitarian which means i've been
reading scripture
with my metaphorically speaking
egalitarian glasses on which of course
influences me quite powerfully
um in terms of how i read the text you
know what i notice or pay close
attention to
verse the passages i just sort of scan
over quickly um
because they you know are in tension
with my egalitarian reading uh
and and not that i didn't know these
texts like we're in the bible or
something
um but just simply that you know once
you have a certain viewpoint
and a certain theological outlook it's
just human that confirmation bias kind
of kicks in
and so any bible verses that align with
your view it's like they jump off the
page
you know and you maybe have this
experience with other things you know
what you're kind of looking for you see
lo and behold
uh and so that was kind of my experience
while anything
that kind of pushes back on your view
you know if that sort of
fades into the background but this all
changed kind of recently
um one day i was leading a couple
through pre-marital counseling
about a year and a half ago and
there was a page of the curriculum that
was devoted to quotation after quotation
of the types of passages that a good
complementarian
would would use to kind of defend their
position and i knew the purpose
um was to kind of get this happy couple
talking about their own theological
views
um the church i worked at previously um
was in fact it was an egalitarian church
but they knew you need to get couples
you know talking about their theology
and talk about this stuff before they
get married hopefully
preferably so that you know they can
flesh that out and have those
conversations so
um but but this page what happened is i
basically began to read
these out loud because we were going to
discuss them in this premarital
counseling session
and yeah as i read um
i just i mean just full disclosure i
just started to feel a little bit
queasy very nervous um because there was
something about having them all kind of
condensed like in one page
you know it's something different about
when you kind of interact with them in
scripture kind of sporadically but
all condensed into one page it just sort
of it sucker punched me
theological sucker punch and then added
to this was the fact that i knew
these folks i was counseling with this
this couple um you know they were pretty
new christians
and they they had cert i think almost
certainly had not read you know through
the bible or
had no idea these kinds of texts were in
there and so they just weren't prepared
and i kind of knew this
and so i was oh what a moment so um
for example i want to give you a few of
the passages it was these types of
passages honestly i can't remember
exactly which ones it was
but it was these these types um
and so like for example see first
corinthians 11
7 through 9 says a man ought not to
cover his head
since he is the image and glory of god
but
woman is the glory of man for man did
not come
from woman but woman from man
neither was man created for woman
but woman for man
um all right another one this is i don't
know if it's maybe it's better that i'm
not
in person with you all i'm this i would
be just curious as a cat
about the looks on people's faces during
these all right first corinthians 14 34
and 35
women should remain silent in the
churches they are not allowed to speak
but must be in submission as the law
says if they want to inquire about
something
they should ask their own husbands at
home for it
is disgraceful for a woman to speak
in the church uh here's another text
from first timothy chapter 2 verses 11
through 14.
a woman should learn in quietness in
full submission
i do not permit permit a woman to teach
or to assume
authority over a man she must be quiet
for adam was formed first then eve
and adam was not the one deceived
it was the woman who was deceived and
became
a sinner uh finally
ephesians 5 20. can you see why i was
getting a little something about having
them all just boom boom boom boom
it's kind of overcooking my grits um
ephesians 5 22 wives submit yourselves
to your own husbands
as you do to the lord
uh so as i read these you know i'm
counseling um well specifically i
remember
looking at the man i was counseling with
and he just sort of looking at me
like is this a trap or what
what am i what do i do with this like i
mean you're a pastor so presumably
you adore these texts but then but my
wife is
or my you know fiance sitting here uh i
mean it was so gosh and then the
the uh the sweet lady she's looking at
me kind of
half puzzled half angry kind of look on
her face
and so i did go on to point out at least
for this last passage is ephesians 5
um we just read verse 22 i did point out
verse 21 the previous verse of course
says submit to one another out of
reverence for christ that kind of frames
it and so i
kind of explained in my own marriage i
have found it's very helpful to practice
what is known as mutual submission and
they both kind of nod their heads
in slight relief as they mumbled oh yeah
yeah
yeah mutual submission that sounds good
that seems that seems best
um and then i made a mental note i
needed to
talk to the team about updating the
premarital counseling materials
like i said this is at a previous church
this is not the same materials we use
okay so
um now now what were they i'm not trying
to
uh i mean you know if you've been with
me in this series i'm not trying to like
mock the bible or you know poke fun it
or whatever um
but i'm trying to i mean it's the series
right dealing with difficult texts and i
think
if you read those um or
if you follow along with me that's yeah
they were kind of awkward
um so what were this this couple what
was i
perhaps you as you listen to me just now
um
you know what are you reacting to
um and i think it's the fact that when
you simply
read them back to back to back um you
get the distinct feeling
that um you know they're just kind of
there's a sex this kind of
tinge to them maybe that's putting that
nicely um it's almost as though the
writer is kind of trying to
you know kind of reign the women in to
to kind of um
maybe bridle them to kind of keep them
in their place a little bit
um and uh of course that begs the
question like why would they be trying
to do that
uh now one of the best kept secrets
of the early church is the central
role that not only women as a whole but
specifically women leaders
that's right women leaders um
women not at all keeping quiet women
definitely exercising authority over
others including men
um one of the best kept secrets is the
enormous part
they played in the rise of early
christianity
uh women were absolutely essential to
the spread of the good news of jesus
there is evidence for this
um not just you know outside the bible
but in both in the new testament
um and in historical documents um we
have from the second century and on
so i want to walk you through through
some of this this would be kind of the
the other track
um so at some level this kind of begins
with jesus himself
who uh while of course the 12 disciples
were all males he did have
a number of other basically women
disciples um who traveled with him
and um even helped kind of fund the
ministry
and um and as we'll see in just a second
women really were the first preachers
of um the resurrection of christ so this
is um
luke 24 if you were with us for a
previous series on the gospel of luke
you'll probably recognize it this is 24
verses 9 through 11.
it says when they came back from the
tomb they told
all these things to the 11 and to all
the others so who is this
they it was mary magdalene joanna
mary the mother of james and the others
with them who
told this to the apostles right so this
is the women telling the men
um but then the men said but it says but
they did not believe the women
because their words seemed to them like
nonsense they just couldn't believe like
resurrection like what
um so basically here you have women
disciples
you know who followed jesus and they
became the first people to
to um testify about the resurrection uh
but really things got going with the
apostle paul
who seemed to intuit that the
resurrection of jesus had
had really ushered in um something he
called new creation
it was the idea of the inbreaking of
heaven
to earth and and and so whatever
kind of messed upness um
relational um fracturing whatever had
been broken or fractured between
people um whatever enmity or strife had
arisen
previously between people um
he and he's thinking of course um here
of the curse of genesis 3 if you recall
the the story you know after everything
went down with the tree the knowledge of
good and evil where god
said um you know do not eat from this
tree he told that to adam and eve but
then eve ate
and then she gave some to adam and then
he ate and then god's like no and then
he
god curses the man and says okay you'll
not have to toil hard for your food
and then to the woman he says now child
bearing will be painful and you'll be
subject to your husband and he will rule
over you that's genesis 3. um and
in which by the way notice in the
passages read earlier
that they're the writer is looking back
to that story
um but paul's insight was that the
resurrection of jesus
hallelujah and amen has undone all of
that
and so his idea seems to be that
christian families and churches
were to be walking talking living
breathing
examples of of new creation of
of a new day a new way of relating of
of heaven touching earth which is why in
galatians chapter 3
paul wrote insane passages
at least passages that would have
sounded insane to the broader
greco-roman world in which he
and his hearers were living passages
like this
so in christ jesus you were all
children of god through faith for
all of you who were baptized into christ
have clothed yourselves with
christ verse 28 there is neither jew
nor gentile neither slave nor free
nor is there male and female for you are
all one in christ jesus what is paul
saying well he's
he's taking groups of people who are
different and
divided in different spheres and and
he's saying look the old days
are over so he looks at for example the
religious
sphere jew and the non-jew or known as
gentile
um he looks at the economic sphere back
then it was slave
and free and finally he looks at the
sphere of gender
male female and he says uh there
is now a a oneness
a unity and equality
in christ jesus and there are honestly
echoes of this
all throughout the new testament um from
for example acts chapter 2
where the holy spirit of god falls upon
not just the men but on everyone
young old rich poor male female they are
all filled with god's spirit
and they all begin to go into the
streets and prophesy and speak god's
word
um to acts 18 verse 26 which says that a
husband-wife pear
named priscilla and aquila uh and notice
that actually the woman was named first
um where basically they took uh took a
man named apollos aside and they taught
him about jesus
so here you have in acts 18 26 a
woman um with her husband teaching a man
uh and then you have also kind of
numerous um
closing credits of paul's letters if
you've ever
read one of paul's letters and it's this
is probably the part you skip
um because at the very end and it's the
part where basically he's just thanking
a lot of people
and he's like hey you know this person
and that person they helped me
and so-and-so hosted a church at their
home and so and so were elders and
leaders in that community just thank you
thank you i'm so grateful
um some of you know what i'm talking
about and uh of course you know it's
very easy to skip through that
but if you read them and pay attention
the list
is not thank you bill harold
jim bob and chris um instead it's really
interesting to note
all the women he mentions here's this is
a great example
uh from romans chapter 16 beginning in
verse
one uh he says i commend to you our
sister
phoebe a deacon of the church in
uh sincrea now a deacon was someone who
basically
helped the leaders of the church execute
on the vision
um in the community but he keeps going
skipping now this is verse three
greet priscilla and aquila my co-workers
in christ jesus they risked their lives
for me
not only i but all the churches of the
gentiles are grateful to them
greet also the church that meets at
their
house so here it sounds like we have um
priscilla
as as almost a co-apostle over
churches or at the very least um this is
you know a husband and wife pair
who are basically elder leaders together
over the church that meets in their
house and um as many of you know in
church communities elders that tends to
be
kind of the highest leadership team in
any church
um you also have to see this is verse
six
uh greet mary who worked very hard for
you
uh then go down verse seven greet
andronicus
and junia my fellow jews who have been
in prison with me
they are outstanding among the apostles
and they were in christ before i was
so um if you know you're greek then you
know that junia
is a woman's name and apparently she was
an outstanding
apostle and an apostle is someone who
um who oversees the leaders of a church
they're like the leaders of the leaders
so
junior certainly said words in church
and
definitely told men what they needed to
do she was
she's basically the peer of the apostle
paul in fact in ways it seems like he's
kind of
you know looking up to them uh so
all right then you add to this that's
all kind of new testament evidence
um add to that the work of sociologists
like um rodney stark and historian tom
holland
and what you see in the decades
following
paul um and and really
even the first few hundred years of
christianity is basically that women
absolutely flocked to
the early church in fact by our best
estimates um churches were basically
two-thirds women uh now this kind of
begs the question of
why um so if you're notetaker you can
jot some of these down
so first churches offered women real
opportunities for engagement
and even leadership uh in the leadership
pieces some of those texts that we saw
earlier
um christianity also promoted sexual
purity
among both sexes so in much of the
ancient world uh the idea
was basically that that women were held
to
very very strict standards
um women and specifically in a marriage
um while the men were kind of free to do
as they want um
like sexually speaking um and that was
true in much of the greco-roman world so
all of a sudden you have this you know
new jesus movement
and women and men are um being held to a
high standard of you know marital
faithfulness and so that was very
appealing
to women um also christians had very
high standards for
divorce uh again in much of the ancient
world
men swapped out their wives very easily
often leaving
women destitute because back in the
greco-roman world you didn't just like
go down the street and get a job
um if you were a woman that wasn't
really a thing so once you know their
husband kind of swapped them out
well then all of a sudden um they're you
know really struggling so
they they flock to christianity because
it had these high standards
again for men of saying like hey no
we're not just
divorcing on a whim like we're committed
to each other we're gonna do our best to
work this out
um so it was very high standards um for
divorce and then finally
um christians condemned infanticide
so this was um very popular in the
ancient world
it was basically leaving a baby outside
in the elements to die
of exposure and this was often done
to female babies because financially
boys were going to grow up and be more
lucrative financially
lucrative and to be able to support
their parents in their old age because
back in that day right kids were
basically your retirement
um and so this is also a factor
as to why um within just a few century
churches
had a lot of young girls and women um
because they they didn't practice
infanticide and
um so all right so you kind of have
these these two different histories so
perhaps your i don't know what you're
experiencing right now maybe a little
bit of
like intellectual whiplash as you wonder
like okay so wait what
so why why those those
passages you opened with brett like what
what's going on with the bible
um that's a good question and one theory
is that um it was really kind of paul
the apostle paul who discerned
the social implications of the good news
of jesus and specifically what it meant
for women and so it was kind of he who
was pushing for this among early
churches
um but perhaps you know or not perhaps
for sure not everyone agreed with paul
and they were quite nervous about this
new development of gender equality
um so perhaps that's kind of what's
happening
perhaps these passages are really just
focused on specific churches with
specific
problems or something um you know but
ultimately i'll kind of leave that
um for the bible scholars to you know
sort out
but what we have to grapple with
as really as you know christians um is
that when it comes to women
and leadership in the church you have
um in the new testament you have two
different trajectories
um both of which someone could argue
and say like you know this is biblical
this is one of the problems with um
people often tack that word you know
biblical
onto a phrase you know biblical marriage
um well like what is biblical marriage
you could i mean there's a lot of um
polygamy in the old testament you know
so is that biblical
and it's kind of the same here right
biblical womanhood as rachel
evans and her wonderful book talks about
um you know what what is
biblical woman of the biblical stance of
women in leadership
right and as we've seen it's not at all
that clear so you kind of have these
you know two different trajectories and
so
probably won't surprise you to hear me
say
that i think our choice of which
trajectory to follow
is super super clear i just i believe
it's beyond time for christians
to really um reclaim this egalitarian
history and this theological vision
of equality in how
the different genders relate to one
another in in the family in the church
in society
and i just i long for us to be a
community
that celebrates and elevates women uh i
wants to be a church who communicates to
our little girls
that they can be fully themselves
and and certainly leaders too
uh that they get to use um their voices
and be heard too that they like this is
our name right the table
they have a place at the table uh
why because in christ
we are all one we are
all equal we are all children
of god well let me go ahead and pray for
you
lord jesus i i ask
that as a community
we would live into this and
where women have been oppressed
and pushed to the edges and
kind of muffled ignored
god i pray that we would start to change
that
that by your grace by your spirit you
would lead us into a new day
and help us to really love one another
um help us to elevate women
and god wherever there's hurt i'm i just
know there's
um some ladies who are listening who
have experienced a lot of hurt
around the church in them in their own
hearts and minds and they um they just
haven't felt really valued and i
um i pray god that you would bring
healing to them
and that their experience in this church
community um
well it's it's probably not going to be
perfect and flawless god but it would be
better
it would be life-giving healing for them
god may it be a new day
and i pray that not only over our church
community but
every church god in our area
in this in this country in our world god
that
that the there would be a profound shift
and that women would be set free
to use their gifts and um
voices and and just who they are god
would be unleashed
and i know we're all going to be better
for it
so we love you lord we love one another
help us to be faithful to live into this
egalitarian vision
in the powerful name of jesus i pray
amen
she is not something to simply take
two years up and throw away claim her
own
to appease you not a dog
not a toy on a string
not a pretty little thing just to lie
down
and please
that's good spit straw
fish and feminine she is
woman woman
from love herself got herself
body blood and soul she's a beautiful
woman
beautiful girl
[Music]
she's
love herself got her
she's beautiful woman
beautiful girl
[Music]
oh
and know you are hurt and you are not
alone you are a beautiful woman
beautiful soul
[Music]
oh bro thank you so much for um sharing
that with
us and thank you all so much for
coming this evening if you're in need
of prayer or support just if you
wouldn't mind just send
us a message in facebook
and we will have one of our leaders
reach out to you
and also for those of you who support
the table financially
just thank you so much your guests
continue to
give us allow us to do the work and to
support organizations like five globes
pantry and saxy
um so for those of you who would like to
support
us if you wouldn't mind going to the
website the table
tx.com and you can select
giving and at the top of the page
for those of you don't forget right
after this service we are doing the
welcome to
the table class so a link will be in the
description below
so make sure you stick around for that
and as we close tonight
i want to send you off with this
benediction
it's from second corinthians 13 13.
may the grace of the lord jesus christ
and the love of god
and the fellowship of the holy spirit be
with you all
thank you and have a good night
you